más dinero para los diputados
el congreso
aprueba subir el sueldo de todos los diputados
del congreso un 3
con el voto en contra del partido popular y de vox
te cuento todos los detalles en este vídeo
pero antes como siempre
sígueme y dame a like
si quieres que siga creando este tipo de contenido
por si no han tenido
poco después
de la renovación de todos los teléfonos móviles
con iphone 14
de los componentes del congreso de los diputados
ahora la cámara de congreso
ha aprobado una subida de sueldo del 3,5%
de todos los diputados a partir de enero de 2023
se trata de más de una subida acorde
a la propuesta del ejecutivo
para los empleados públicos
y que además
fue negociada entre el gobierno y los sindicatos
como decimos
tanto pp como vox se han opuesto a esta subida
que también contó
con el rechazo de ciudadanos
pero bueno su voto no cuenta
porque no tienen representación en esa mesa
además el presupuesto para el congreso
para el 2023 ascenderá un 10